every night when I crawl out of my grave  looking for someone to meet somewhere  that will misbehave  [Music]  is  [Music]  when I pull them closer to me  bloody Sunrise comes again leaves me  hungry and alone  every time  bloody sunrise  [Music]  bloody sunrise  [Music]  every night I put on my smartest threads  and I go into the town and I don't even  look dead  every night I smile and I say hi and no  one ever smiles back and if I could I'd  just die  but when I'm lucky I do get lucky  you might be the one  even though the time is flying  when it gets to the Time of Dying  Sunrise comes again leaves me hungry and  alone  every time  bloody sunrise  sunrise  [Music]  foreign  [Music]